all right a Harvard sorority just
announced they're going gender-neutral
Kappa Alpha Theta if that's their real
name will actually be changing its name
to linking itself from its national
chapter all because Harvard Penn Eliza's
its members by withholding student
leadership positions as well as other
perks while still charging them of
course 60 grand a year I know it's hard
to care about a Harvard sorority talk
about a rough life but it's a slow news
day and clubs and clubs by nature are
club' people join based on shared traits
hobbies and so on if you like stamps you
join a Stamp Club if you like
motorcycles you join the Hells Angels in
high school I couldn't join the boys
chorus because I couldn't sing and I
couldn't join the girls chorus because I
went to an all-boys school I could only
sing in the shower often by myself it
was pure hell but I managed but the
irony of forcing inclusivity on clubs is
that inevitably clubs go away it's not
worth the trouble
society is now in a gender panic where
it's scandalous to say that boys and
girls are different and that they like
different things
I've yet to run into a single male who
likes maroon 5
[Music]
I think you see my point there
and so circus social circles will likely
fold to pressure from self-serious
college administrators maybe that's why
everyone prefers to live on social media
for maybe it more closely resembles real
life with friends enemies insult jokes
insights and genius Edie it's 60 grand a
year cheaper is it true data think
that's true you make a very good point
thank you thank you very much which one
it was like to be in a club right
because if you're on social media
remember it was just last week that that
actor dil pass whatever yeah in trouble
because with all of his friends and his
club because he said maybe you if you
want to follow somebody that might not
totally agree with you try ben shapiro
and then okay then his club wanted to
yes and also a huge concern right now
for people is the destruction of civil
society right and part of that is that
people don't belong to clubs yes anymore
need clothes like Rotary Club things
like people would get together and do
things put on the parade have the event
help assimilate immigrants things like
that this is actually a very interesting
point that you made yes you know what
okay there are other cool if there are
black fraternities you would people
would go crazy if you tried to say okay
black fraternities have to accept white
people or gay gay fraternities have to
accept straight people I mean sororities
is a sorority a sorority anymore if it
is gender-neutral I guess I think its
roots are as yeah it's a female
organization but I mean so much of this
is kind of reactionary if you will I
mean like you were talking about black
fraternities blacks or I guess what they
were created because they weren't black
people were not allowed into like white
ones right and with the women's thing
it's interesting you know the male
fraternities are the ones especially in
places like Harvard Princeton Yale
they're the ones that have all the
tradition and the power and the secret
societies and women bones right and
women for the longest time we're saying
hey how come we can't get it you know I
mean what was the Radcliffe Rite was the
girls school and Harvard the boys school
remember all that's shifted so we've
seen changes and for the most part I
think it's good Greg I think that
should be able to go but the worry would
be that and I think you hear this from a
lot of women who argue that you need
women's schools more women's colleges
because that's where women get to be
stupid it's so done if someone wants to
start a club and everyone calls
themselves a Z why not you do your thing
why can't I be a part of a sorority and
we're all she's this I just think that
this is so stupid and I also think it's
just underscores and demonstrates the
totalitarianism of the left in the sense
if they don't like something they shut
it down we were seeing this with free
speech as well now with free association
and I think it's a big problem and I
just think at the Edit side I just don't
I just think it's so stupid I know but
they're penalizing you to a point where
it makes it very difficult to try to be
a part of one's you know if you remain
closed you have you should be exactly so
you can no longer be a sorority or a
fraternity therefore if you do as a
single gender organization then you get
punished by the administration through
things like yeah through things like
barring people from holding positions
things of that nature you can still be a
join another Club and everyone can be
whatever you want to be Jesse you can
all be unicorns I don't care hey leave
unicorns out of this Jesse
we keep hearing about how important it
is to have safe spaces couldn't you
argue that a sorority is the safe space
for women and fraternities I mean it's
like it's kind of strange men kind of
wouldn't mind living with women but
women do not want to live with men we're
disgusting and obnoxious and we're gonna
be making all kinds of loud noises in
the middle of the night they need their
space to be girls yeah guys don't
necessarily need that because we just
like spread out like and do our thing
this is why I didn't go to Harvard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
for the five to Adam Levine and when
were in five-point I think it's about
busybodies yeah this is one it's like
the straws and this it's like there's a
lot so much good news there's nothing
left to complain about they go out their
sororities well I think we all learned a
lesson here that jesse has terrible
taste in music you do
come on route 5 do you actually listen
to that yeah listen you have trash metal
on the bump in that ya Iron Age album
it's very good Iron Age is music Brune
was actually not very good oh it was
great
she's given me Iron Age Oh in the Iron
Age very funny joke